en la medida que pasan los días crece la
ansiedad dentro del sistema de la
república islámica Y son más las voces
que piden porque se acaben por fin esas
protestas que ya entran en la cuarta
semana de hecho hay algunas voces
incluida el jefe de la justicia que ha
tratado de crear lazos con un sector de
la población ese que llaman ellos que no
crean los disturbios en la calle para
crear un lazos de comunicación y no
solamente esos jóvenes que están en la
calle sino por ejemplo hoy también se
unían a estas protestas los trabajadores
de una de las refinerías más importantes
del país en el Golfo Pérsico donde
cantaban eslogans también en contra de
los líderes de la República islámica
especialmente el líder alija menei y
ellos se unían también a un sector del
comercio especialmente en Teherán de
esos grandes bazares de la ciudad que
también se unieron a las protestas el
pasado sábado es así como el jefe de la
justicia decía venga conversemos todos
juntos y tienen problemas con la
República islámica si tienen preguntas
hagá Esta no es la primera vez que se
tratan de crear esos lazos de
comunicación sin éxito hasta el momento
y también llegan un momento en que
tratan de hacer una campaña para lavar
la imagen de la policía y de las fuerzas
de seguridad en el país pero esto sucede
realmente cuando siguen circulando
videos de ataques especialmente a esos
jóvenes y esto es especialmente evidente
en la ciudad de San Andrés en la región
del gurdistán iraní donde las presión y
la represión es bastante grande en los
últimos días tanto allí que las
universidades y colegios están cerradas